you're expecting how are you feeling  good but had a rough first trimester  breath I mean I feel like people don't  really prepare you for how hard it can  be have you talked about names nursery  planning going on what are the one of  the steps with you right now all of it  we're talking about boy names and girl  names and it's hard it's like how do you  name a human being it's like really  really hard uh and then I like joke cuz  we were just watching bring it on and I  was like what's up torrent I really like  the name torrents okay you know  depending on what what we have we're  just excited and we talk about names we  nursery the our garage is just full of  baby stuff so we're ready like they'll  give you come tomorrow and we'd be okay  are you guys gonna find out boy or girl  um we are yes we plan to find out um we  you know we just couldn't wait I don't  know how people wait that long I do not  have that kind of patience like I need  to know